flexbox is one of the most powerful
tools that you can use for layout it's
changed a lot in the last couple years
but at this point it's hit candidate
recommendation and it's supported by
most browsers in this class I'm just
going to show you the current syntax but
in your code and for anything you're
building for production I want you to
make sure that you're including all of
the vendor prefixed versions so that way
if anybody is on an older browser you're
not leaving them out in the cold
the reason flexbox is so powerful is its
ability to fill the space available if
an element has extra room around it
it'll expand to fit or if it's getting
crowded elements will shrink so that
they've take up as little space as
possible let me show you an example flex
box makes it super easy to position
elements left or right without floats
you could also change the order of
elements without changing HTML and flex
box makes it really easy to accomplish a
lot of other common layout techniques
pete how do you approach design with
flex boxes well let me show you cool